soixante deux rescapés au départ de la
15e étape toulon anton la chaleur et
tropicales on en boit et on fait comme
les estivants on prend un bain de mer
une baignade entre deux coups de pédales
c'est aussi ça le tour de france en 1950
les cyclistes font comme ils peuvent
pour se rafraîchir en pleine canicule
ans en 1961 rebelote mais cette fois la
méditerranée n'est pas sur leur route à
une fontaine un arrêt il y à de
l'entente entre les régionaux quand on a
soif pas question de distinguer les
maillots quant à monza n'est qu'ici il a
vraiment une formule toute personnelle
de se rafraîchir à le tour de france
dans ces années là c'est aussi
l'occasion de voir les cyclistes réparer
eux-mêmes leur vélo comme ici loup ils
ont gobé en pleine grimpette d'un col en
1950 car oui à l'époque il fallait
prendre sa chambre à air de rechange
autour du cou le tour de france c'est le
tour de la débrouille pad équipes
techniques aux petits soins alors quand
on a soif en 1963 et bien on s'arrête au
bistrot 2010 pour les coureurs c'est le
sar le pays de la spa par une chaude
journée il arrive ça transpire état ou
quatre lignes alors ils voient ils
boivent n'importe quoi ce qui leur tombe
sous la main de la pied du vin rouge du
champagne des chocolats glacés
bières vins champagnes saïd raté en plus
ça a aidé à pédaler plus vite
autre solution filmé lors d'une
ascension d'un grand col pyrénéen en
1970 il nous a semblé intéressant alors
que toutes les caméras étaient braquées
sur les premiers de rester dans la roue
des derniers première constatation la
poussette dite à l'italienne a aussi ses
adeptes en france et allez hop comme je
te pousse voilà je pense une poussette
record une poussette bien organisé une
poussette harley c'est interdit mais
c'est un peu une bonne action qui serait
tout pardonné par l'abbé joubert un abbé
passionnés du christ et du cyclisme en
1962 c'est l'un des commissaires du tour
un commissaire en soutane quand un
coureur man ou lorsqu'il agit alors
qu'ils trichent disant ok qu'est ce que
vous éprouvez à ce qu'on vous avez une
double situation
oui je sais pas s'ils trichent
c'est par lui que tricher on n'a pas
triché plein fouet vous pouvez vous
soumettre à toutes les obligations d'un
prêtre alors que l'imam est facilement
le matin ce qui est sûr c'est que
certains cyclistes aurait bien eu besoin
de se confesser
en 1961 c'est face caméra que des
cyclistes par lé sourire aux lèvres de
salé la soupe talent est là sous un
coureur qui marchent pas trop
d'habitudes jour au lendemain si ce
n'est avec l'abolition du kayak du salé
l'ass ou celui vécu c'est la télévision
c'est que mais la dose dans le petit
bidon
voilà à quoi ressemble et le tour de
france quand il était encore en noir et
blanc
[Musique]